foreign
ing these good morning everyone I'm
opening the subcommittee meeting on
Centerville 203 relative to the board of
manufactured housing
and I believe
do you have the bill itself uh yes
okay
and uh representative McGuire has an
amendment
um have all interested parties seen the
oh
okay it's it's amendment number 1365 H I
have more copies here if anybody doesn't
okay it's yeah take a couple
yes and I'd like to explain this yes
please
um
this amendment deletes the restructuring
of the board
that's partly because we weren't
convinced by the testimony that the
board needed to be restructured and
partly because the house position is as
expressed in House Bill 2 is that the
board is deleted
so as that's our position we aren't
going to mess with the composition of
the board
however the
testimony did indicate that the website
for the board has a lot of useful data
particularly from the early days when it
was more active and so this amendment
simply tells the oplc
to maintain that website for five years
that's long enough for some other or
some other board if necessary to take
over the structure
and it will preserve the data that we
have and
um
since that doesn't cost much
to just to maintain the website the oplc
has agreed to doing that with no trouble
and I think that five years is long
for for a successor
organization if one is needed to be
created
nope
um I would invite
I see a representative hunt here who
actually our committee felt that this
feel more likely would have gone to his
committee
so I have invited him this morning to
all right
um is there anyone else who would care
okay
um
I'm supposed to have
five members so we have a quorum
representative shewitt
so do I have a motion to
um yes
I did oh sorry I didn't hear you
those in favor of the amendment
just verbal
hi okay so the amendment is being put
forward three to nothing
and that will be the recommendation to
the full committee
um again pointing out that
um the board has technically been
deleted by virtue of the house passing
hv2 that therefore becomes the house
physician and it will now be a matter of
I'm sure discussion in any Committee of
conference between the House and Senate
going if the Senate chooses not to
delete it yeah they that's that's the
next step but in any event that as
amended this bill will keep the data
available no matter what the Senate does
and no matter what type of success or
organization is decided on yep
okay so I move out to pass with
Amendment
all right all those in favor
aye
again three to nothing okay I thank you
do you think Sherry is okay
I don't know we can we've got a couple
of minutes
foreign
a few more people yeah well
three is better than many of you you
know
all right and we will exec on this in
two weeks on Wednesday that's angel
yes so we'll let him uh
burst himself
okay so that's that I'll give birth to
care
a couple of minutes before I hit the
dentist
upset
District 32 which is New Ipswich Wilson
Temple oh okay yeah
I represent uh you have such like the
most conservative town in New Hampshire
and uh which is why I was elected which
was why all three of us representatives
in that District were elected because
Temple uh posted
we were losing by like 70 to 80s and so
the next day news which hadn't voted yet
they were saying hey sorry to win I'm
like no I did because I knew that I knew
before midnight
wait till New and search posts and we
got to do two thirds of votes which one
all right so uh opening the subcommittee
meeting
so opening the subcommittee meeting on
Centerville 147
and
um we had before us the amendment which
I had drafted
which we heard quite a bit of pushback
on
oh welcome representative Schmidt
um
is this the same Amendment you gave out
at the hearing yeah
would you um
would you care to sit in it for Michael
Brian
all right
okay
um so is
do we see any part of the proposed
amendment that we want to use or just go
to the bill to
I think this whole section
is
way too deep in the details
and I understand there's another bill in
HHS considering this whole issue
so I would like to eliminate this whole
change to
um
The rulemaking Authority regarding
anesthesia and the only thing that as I
understand it we need to include
is on the bill itself on paper
well I I think
um what we heard was the addition of one
dentist member
who administers general anesthesia that
makes perfect sedation should be added
to the board right the other thing that
that would be important was on page two
line nine pair subparagraph e
yes permits to Denver for the facilities
yes and that's in the version amended by
the Senate
right and I I think that's that's
something that the oplc told us was
important because otherwise you end up
with
uh multiple
multiple inspections
it whenever a person changes so if you
get a facility permit
you just have to check that the people
are there and not
um not deal with the inspections and
um I think the bill does need further
amending
um per
um Miss Courtney from VLC
and I don't know if I caught everything
um she talked about on page three line
ten the fee setting because and I
understand that that's
um agreeable
to the Dental Board is that correct to
let opiel see uh set the fees that's
already in place
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
okay and um well I think that the
uh
yes we definitely want to change that
language and we'll need to get
the appropriate uh citation
and and I will just state to the folks
who approached me
to put forward the amendment
my understanding is correct that
amendment was proposed to the Senate
Health and Human Services committee for
Senate field 91 is that pretty much
correct
the issue of
could you come to the microphone sorry
representative representative Schmidt he
he testified at the initial hearing he's
a nurse anesthetist who specialize is an
we had a little difficulty with our
scheduling because we're this is the
only subcommittee that's actually
working on specific Center bills the
so um I'll just State further that
um we kind of feel like the the question
of sedation should more properly be
handled by a committee that deals with
Health and Human Services our committee
was to look at the rules particularly so
I think until that issue is resolved by
that committee
addressing it for rules could be
a little problematic if we agree to
something premature I demand that so yes
I'd be happy to speak to that um
actually the original SB 147 did not
contain any changes to the sedation
rules
um and in fact as I understand at the
board of dental examiners did not even
put forth an amendment lifting the
exemption uh until the Senate took it up
uh and that amendment was offered uh so
go ahead
oh I'm sorry yes of course
you'd think I would have known this by
now my name is Michael Auerbach for the
record I'm the executive director of the
New Hampshire Dental Society normally I
do not speak to rules changes
um however uh we've been carefully
watching this one because it's had an
impact so as I said
um the original bill which we were very
much in favor of particularly as it
answers a lot of the questions by
putting in a a sedation provider like an
oral surgeon like Dr Abel here on the
board in the first place a lot of those
questions could have been answered so uh
by if you're proposing to remove uh the
changes to section H altogether I don't
think we have a problem with that and we
would like to see that a rule address
we the details of who is where and and
what the requirements are
ought to be defined by
people with more technical background on
it we can
once they've done that we can address
the rulemaking authority but we
shouldn't be setting the The rulemaking
Authority before they've done the
technical work that's backwards
may I just said I'm Dr Mark Abel from
oral surgeon in Manchester I live in
Bedford
um the another important thing that the
bill does
sb147 is it creates an anesthesia uh
committee for the board of dental
examiners
um do you see that you see that on page
yeah I think it's 317 a 2B anesthesia
and sedation committee
so that's absolutely critical because
right now the board of dental examiners
doesn't have an official anesthesia
committee so this is the first time that
the legislature is officially creating
that committee for the board of dental
examiners
well actually all of this would be the
left hand except for
it's
so if I may ask good so Dr Abel you're
supportive of that of that the inclusion
the of such a subcommittee on in the
Dental Board yeah oh absolutely in fact
we had
we had a committee that I was on I was
actually chair of the committee for Num
for a period of time and that committee
had to be disbanded because um when the
Dental Board was audited it was
determined that that committee could not
exist because it was never created by
the legislature well I'm I'm remembering
exactly that that point of uh contention
when the bill was heard before us uh
several months ago they said
you have no legal basis uh to be doing
this because a statute does not address
this at all so
[Music]
down through so down through G we want
to keep yeah I we certainly don't want
to eliminate the requirement that
somebody
who knows about anesthesia is present
Madam chairs is there some uh
possibility we could ask somebody from
the HHS committee to sit in on these
deliberations because I totally agree
that we kind of got the heart the cart
before the horse here uh or the heart
before the course for that matter
representatives in any case there is a
senate field 91 which has been
re-referred by Senate Health and Human
Services and the amendment that was
presented to our committee has is in
their position it was presented to them
that's what I'm saying that to me is the
proper place they're looking at it
they're considering it and I think they
should be the ones to make the those
kinds of decisions I I think that a very
important information I'm glad you were
put that out because I agree but the
bottom line is we we are getting
absolutely ahead of ourselves in this
committee with regard to rules and and
we need to have that that issue
addressed before we
right is there any disagreement on that
you you've joined us late but uh uh
would you like to be heard on this
subject
well
we'll be happy to yes thank you we'll be
happy to uh yes
um the chair will recognize Ms Courtney
who had made a couple recommendations I
think we caught a couple of them but
we'd like to hear from you if you have
this happened to me once I went to the
wrong room and and Georgetown I became a
dentist
it's never happened before so uh yeah
uh I represent the board of dental
examiners and I'd like to thank the
committee for letting me have the
opportunity to present the board's
position on Bill 147.
the National Standard for deep sedation
anesthesia and hospitals and surgery
centers is to have a separate dedicated
provider to administer anesthesia
oral surgeons are the only health care
providers that provide deep sedation
general anesthesia to Pediatric patients
without separate providers
there are seven National recognized
societies comprised of experts in
Pediatric and pediatric anesthesia that
recommend against a single operator
provider model currently used they are
the American Academy of Pediatrics the
American Academy of Pediatric Dentistry
the American yes Society of
anesthesiologists the Society of
pediatric anesthesiology the American
Society of dental anesthesiologists the
American Society of nurse
anesthesiologists the New Hampshire
Association of dental anesthesiologists
the New Hampshire board has been
responsible
to the public to make Dentistry as safe
as possible the sole reason that I'm on
the board is for Public Safety I take
time out of my schedule
I've been researching this for as long
as I've been on the board and so I'm
very passionate about it
when there are so many experts against
the single provider model the board
cannot ignore the inherent risk
associated associated with this practice
we've investigated the impact to access
the care as well as a cost analysis and
found adding a dedicated provider had
minimal effect on the overall picture of
uh the um
surgical theater the boat the the board
voted unanity to have a dedicated
provider for deep sedation for children
under the age of eight
[Music]
um
which is a little different than when
um the oral surgeon brought forth the
exemption for having a dedicated
provider who has had so many hours of
experience in a period of time
this proposal was rejected by the board
of dental examiners the issue is not
surgeon's competency level or experience
it is in fact that they would have not
have enough providers if there was an
emergency
I draw a comparison to Miracle on the
Hudson
uh Captain sullenberg the pilot of
Miracle on the Hudson had 50 years
flying experience 20 000 hours yet he
relied heavily on his second officer
during that emergency so this has
nothing to do with experience it has to
do with handling pediatric deep sedation
so I I believe this is exactly the type
of argument that we heard did we not at
the time that the bill was heard and I
apologize for not making that but uh
um one of the rules that encompers the
board is that we have to be voted
permission to come and talk and I was
given permission to go to the Senate but
they failed to put that in the motion so
I was not allowed to attend the other
meeting
okay thank you very much we
um this part of what you were saying was
presented by Dr tivolt at our hearing
however he did State when he was there
that he was just representing himself he
was not authorized to speak for
um
he does
a vast amount of dental pediatric
anesthesia he's very experienced in that
in that area I understand that but like
I said we had to take him at his word he
said he was just representing well I'll
vote for him he did cite the same uh
groups that you had mentioned but he was
not officially representing them or the
dental examiners
so um I thank you for coming today
um I'm I'm guessing that you are okay
with what we are proposing to remove
section H from the bill I don't have
that in front of me hold on let me I
might have
foreign
I'm sorry from the amendment you're
right the amendment okay well I have an
extra copy of you thank you
the amendment yeah the amendment is
Section Eight yeah
um basically we want to remove section H
from we want to amend the bill to remove
section h
because that's deep into who does what
and not speaking I'm sorry can we just
indicate the line that you're
referencing so the doctor on the bill as
amended by the Senate page 2 line 17 sub
paragraph h
which goes on down through the bottom of
the page
so the amendment as far as the
documentation of cases presented
we're not for that no no no no we want
to take out
we want to take out from the bill
section H which means we don't H which
means we don't want to insert the
yeah you're doctor you're you're looking
at the wrong document if you're looking
at the amendment they're looking at the
original bill so we got to get you a
copy of that
go ahead yeah we're looking at the
amended bill
um the bill amended by the Senate
and my understanding is the proposal
would be to completely eliminate Section
8 of that amended version
yes that's subsection H as in horse yep
and and so the Practical the way I see
that the Practical impact would be that
there would be a second provider
required to be present because there
okay so as far as removing that
exemption I can't
the board we we're and uh that's really
important career
you can use it sir yeah I'm sorry we
just passed
we just passed a rule change
that has gone to oplc to address this
problem so and I'm not really the
problem the problem with single provider
anesthesia in a deep sedation for
Pediatric Dentistry I'm sorry I should
be more clear
and go ahead if I may So currently the
way the statute their current statute
currently reads is that they are allowed
to provide waivers of of having
um the requirement that two persons be
present historically they have always
waived that provision
um the board is now contemplating
um only waving that under certain
circumstances however obviously the
statute Trump's rule so if the statue uh
were to be adopted I think as I'm
reading the amended version of the
Senate taking out Section 8 that
obviously would Trump whatever rules
so again I'll ask is if we just remove
section h
is that going to allow you I assume
you're going to be bringing those rules
so would that mean that we wouldn't have
the board wouldn't have the authority
over it anyways as I was saying
the situation is currently that they
allow waivers right so the support can
can since it's a waiver the board can
decide not to issue any more waivers I
mean that's right right I don't
a statute is not necessarily required a
statutory change with respect to that
issue because the board currently
retains that Authority
um
the word currently retains that
authority to issue waivers or not issue
waivers
and it was pointed out to us that we
previous boards gave a blanket waiver
and during the audit it was pointed out
good thing to do
so hence here we are and I apologize for
my confusion of what law versus the
regulation uh I'm not familiar with that
It Ain't Easy the uh many other people
well if they if the board already has
the authority to do this
I certainly don't want to put it into
statute because it's way beyond our
skills yeah
so and like I said if Senate Health and
Human Services feels that that's within
their Fairview they can come in back
with it next year they've got a bill to
do it if I may Madam chair I do think
that um another portion of this bill 147
what was important to the board was the
establishment of the facility license I
wasn't the person best able to
articulate why the board thought that
was the appropriate model so I don't
know if you want to hear from Dr
Ludington on that issue
well they they spoke to us at the
hearing and that seemed pretty obvious
to all of us yeah I think there's no
problem with that okay you had mentioned
a couple places particularly
item e
the permits for dental facilities we
intend to leave that in
and you had talked about on page
three
line ten
about fee setting yes that that should
should that just be should that entire
thing be deleted or
just who just put a period after fee
yeah
I think I think that would do it but the
board should be deleted deleted
was there any other section that you are
concerned about besides those those two
Madam chair yes I think under that
paragraph B's is documentation of
competence uh we we certainly don't want
to get rid of that
okay and uh so you're you're suggesting
deleting Item B no no not deleting item
okay so that's well that's just gonna
stay there then right yeah well actually
we don't want to make the change we want
to go through G
according to the rules on through G
which includes
the uh
qualifications for deep
facility license the physical presence
of somebody licensed and
um
which are the only changes
yeah that's what I'm so we don't want to
Madam chair there is one other change
that we would propose is that we support
the establishment of the anesthesia and
sedation committee but I was currently
drafted it it limits
um membership to dentists and dentists
are not the only individuals who provide
anesthesia in a dental setting
so we would suggest language to include
those individuals nurse anesthetists and
or anesthesiologists who practice in a
dental setting
I believe
right
one dentist married
and four additional license anesthesia
providers
yeah that's I think that's in here yes
yeah but they're not dentists
the lead for additional providers
okay
which
I have a question at this juncture
whether the Senate's
work at the moment we heard earlier that
the Senate is currently engaged in uh
amending or whatever do we know whether
I don't want to be working at Cross
purposes with what the Senate is doing
or duplicating what they're doing is
there some way we can coordinate uh the
actions of this subcommittee our
committee and the Senate as well with
regard to their bill because it seems
like we're kind of getting someplace
here with this deliberation your
participation the two of you is very
helpful to my understanding of where I
think we should be going but to the
degree that the Senate is doing the same
thing or not quite the same thing I
think we're
not well advised to proceed without
coordinating with them
by May representative
um
so originally uh my understanding was
Senate Bill 147 was just to deal with
the membership of the board as well as
to create the permit structure for
facilities at some point language was
added which is the language in Senate
bill 91.
I think from the board's perspective
it's important to address the facility
issue as well as establishment of the
committee and I think because they
already have the waiver Authority it's
not important to include that language
instead of Bill 147 that could be
addressed Senate Bill 91 if so inclined
but I think the board does desire to
move forward with establishment of
facility permits
just as long as we're coordinating
what's happening and that we're not
so it won't be coming out of
until January right so okay well then
let's get done let's get done what we
can do here that's
and to the degree that to the degree
that the the statute already permits
some of these things uh you know
representative McGuire and I are both on
the joint legislative committee on
administrative rules uh which uh we'll
be hearing the proposal of the Dental
Board in the rules package that they're
working on so I think we have uh
sounds like we're kind of are getting
our feet on the ground here yeah as a as
long as the board has the authority to
issue waivers
then
they're covered for whether they choose
to deny all of them or approve all of
them because it's
their knowledge that determines whether
[Music]
thank you thank you so much um two
things
um I guess I just want to make sure that
the subcommittee is aware
um the history of section H so it was
pre previously section g it was passed
in 2018
and the reason that it was passed was
because the Dental Board has always had
the authority to to and to give
anesthesia permits to dentists that's
always been the board's empowerment by
the legislature but there was a movement
in 2018
that it should be a requirement a
legislative statutory requirement that
dentists have to have a second
anesthesia provider under 13 no matter
what even if the board says they can
they put the exemption in so that the
board Earth so that the board could
exempt oral surgeons and dentist
anesthesiologists but no other dentist
can get that exemption before 2018
the board could give an anesthesia
permit to any dentist to give anesthesia
to any age
so it was really in 2018 that it became
a statutory thing where uh the the
proponents of that bill wanted to
prevent the board from being able to
give permits to give anesthesia to
children under 13 unless they had a
second provider but then we got in the
exemption for oral surgeons in
by deleting this from the the bill we
are not deleting it from the current
statute we are saying we are not going
to change the current statute
is that so
is that is is does that meet your your
concerned
Mike my concerns were just that there
there were voices within the Senate that
were adamant that the legislature should
again intervene statutorily to take the
uh the power away from the board to
provide these permits so I guess when
you go once in Senate Bill 91 which
talks
I don't want to jump to a conclusion
okay yeah as long as long as as long as
the Senate will be in agreement with
taking that part out then no no we're
just not going to make any changes to
current law in that area okay they're
trying to make changes in that and I
figure we'll we'll give them a clean
slate and let them work on it
um maybe I just make one more comment uh
once they have to decide once they
finish their fight Madam chair may just
make one one more comment
um in general I I really like what um Dr
Tebow proposed about the anesthesia
committee the composition of it the only
thing I would add is I know we had had
some discussions and I don't know how Dr
Ludington feels about this but my
understanding was there would be an
anesthesia committee it would have a
chair who would be a dentist there would
be an ex-officio member who would be the
anesthesia Provider from the Dental
Board and then the other three members
could be
anyone dentist nurse anesthetist
whomever that was my understanding but I
don't know how Dr Ludington feels about
that
um well in the practical sense I think
it would I think the board if they had
an anesthesia provider would allow that
had to happen however right now we don't
and so to handcuff the board to only
allow that person to go I think it
should be amended to just have a
representative from the board and I'm
sure the board would send someone that
is involved in the anesthesia part of it
so they would take it upon themselves
when that position is filled to to do
that but right now the way it is if that
happens we have no one that we can send
so there is as the anesthesia provider
on the board that position hasn't opened
yet and so we would create kind of a a
vacancy that we couldn't fill legally
because we couldn't send just any member
of the board having been on the board
realizing that no one's going to
volunteer for that position over and
above the person that's qualified they
would automatically do that but to put
it in the legislative terms I think
would would if that member wasn't
available the board couldn't supplement
someone else it was it could do that the
the bill says that it's one dentist
member of the board okay who has a
permit to administer anesthesia which
sounds like your tradition then it says
four additional dentists permitted to
administer anesthesia and the suggestion
is to change four additional
anesthesia providers
appointed by the board no my thing is
the board member that's sent should be
um a board member period not have the
board member that has anesthesia
experience because as of right now we
have eight members none of them have
that experience so therefore we couldn't
run the committee and um so okay so you
want to delete the requirement that the
dentist from the board member have the
permit right
and you're okay with four additional
providers yes
okay
Dr Tebow has his hand up I think we
should hear from him
may I just make one last Quick comment I
apologize I know one thing that came up
with the public hearing too was um
I guess how this would be implemented so
if you pass this uh Bill and it requires
that one of the board members has an
anesthesia permit currently
none of them do so would someone be
forced off the board or would that just
wait till someone resigns
well we'll go with one board member and
then if you happen to get somebody with
okay
um I know we're not dealing with uh
section H totally off the board but
but I would like to also comment on
I would also like to comment on the um
section that you were just referring to
line 12 with regards to the anesthesia
subcommittee that with regards to the
anesthesia I think it's very important
that the subcommittee be made up of
members of uh people that provide
anesthesia regardless of whether they're
a CRNA a physician a dentist or an oral
surgeon I think it needs to be made up
of everybody because in this Arena
having different perspectives uh I think
facilitates education and that education
would be
um uh probably very beneficial to the
board when they're making decisions with
regards to that you know Dr Abel is an
oral surgeon myself being a nurse
anesthesiologist we have different
perspectives and I think that
perspective will help guide the board of
thank you
I I want to weigh in on this issue of
the second provider yes I I I'm totally
uh on board with the idea that you don't
want to have one person only in that
operating room uh when something an
emergency comes you you simply cannot
have only one person
uh I agree yeah I think that has to be
good
then let's leave it
Madam chair one of the things that that
law allowed us to have a blanket
exemption which
the board's Council and through the
audit was found that that was not
appropriate so that's why we're making
changes to the to the rules as a as as
it is right now because the blanket
exemption is inappropriate for for
maintaining the safety of of the public
yes sir the
the law says may exempt dentists who are
board certified whatever
the interpretation that you can exempt
all dentists who are so
qualified is
not correct I mean you can't give a
blanket exemption right well we were you
could still exempt them one at a time or
for specific occasions right which is
you're absolutely right and we were
scolded on that although it happened
prior to me being there I still got
scolded for it I think which is okay at
the end of the day we're going to
correct that
um
Madam chair would you suggest us
repealing that exemption as soon as
possible or wait until we have the other
rule in place if it's inappropriate to
give blanket exemptions you should
probably repeal it quickly okay and say
that individuals
May apply for specific exemption I
appreciate your advice because that's
that's what needs okay thank you
although I'm not a lawyer I only pretend
to be one but it would seem to say that
you may exempt them but
um that's okay thank you for that yeah
and that's the current law that they
they may accept Madam chair
yep as a former Child Welfare worker and
the mother of a pediatric nurse
practitioner with her doctorate degree I
would say act now okay thank you very
much
mm-hmm
[Music]
and
coordinate with Ms Courtney to be sure
we've included
um
specifications that she's put forward
and
um hopefully have it ready for when our
committee execs what did you say two
weeks yep
so that's the plan uh if if uh folks
want to pursue the case for under eight
years old that's the purview of the
Senate Health and Human Services
committee so I'm sure you'll be working
with them over the summer on that bill
Senate Bill 91
and hopefully that will come to house
health and youth services
right
so do I have a motion to adjourn
okay
thank you
sure if I've got
even understand I started with my red
pin
um
if you want me I'll draft an amendment
and give it to you and if you like it
you can send it to OLS that sounds great
okay center after a minute all right I
think
and I do have I was looking for it I'm
pretty sure it was house filled
1577 or 78 from 2018
right here well I just wrote that but I
had it written someplace else because I
did look at it what's the one I'll make